[Music]
i do have some slides and i'm not gonna
i'm gonna try to deviate and get into
the code as much as possible
uh and demos but a lot of this requires
some context
so we'll do that let's start off with
docker promises
to
help you build ship and run your
applications and
image pipelines are all about the
building and shipping part ultimately we
want to get software from our source
control system
to production quickly
and you know we have developers who are
all the way on the left side of the
process
and you know they're working hard and
building things and
and uh then we have operators
uh who are running those things
sometimes they're the same people
oftentimes they're different in the
middle there can be a bunch of sadness
this guy
is on the cover of docker in action but
i assure you
uh i wore my
docker in action containers make it
better shirt today
hopefully you can see this so docker
packages software into images for easy
handling and running
and
you know in some sense if you're not
familiar with docker images that's okay
i mean doctor in action the book will
teach you all about that if you if you
want to learn about it uh
but ultimately you can think of them as
essentially a zip file with a bunch of
uh
information attached to it that makes it
easy to
run package all your application
and its dependencies inside of the image
and then run it
and it's
designed
for automation to be able to move these
things these images around
and inspect them and so forth and we're
going to see a bit about that today name
them properly attach metadata etc let's
go back to that image again there's a
number of jobs to be done when it comes
to delivering software we have to
package software and its dependencies
uh we have to verify the package is good
we have to label
uh like identify it name it
we have to store the package
and we have to deploy the right thing
uh and then ultimately we have to run
that with the right configuration for
that environment and sometimes that's
not all that easy let's dig into image
pipelines because that's what's going to
help us take care of like
all the concerns
uh that we
showed on that page an image pipeline is
a way to model that process
and and solve those concerns that i just
talked about
kind of uh
with a process that is designed to
satisfy those concerns we're very much
interested in correctness both in
putting the right things into our image
and then making sure that that image is
uh configured to run properly what we're
going to do is we're going to prepare to
build the image by checking out the
clean source code and either creating
that application
right there or retrieving dependencies
and i recommend you put your doctor file
the thing that defines your image and
and the thing that and the process the
code that
defines the image's build process
right in the application source
and that way it's
under the same version control as the
rest of your application
uh it's really no different
like it's just there are many aspects of
what go into a docker image that are
just as important as
the apple as many of the bits of
application code
so it makes sense to to version and
change them together track their changes
together we need to be able to like get
a clean copy of the source code with our
instructions for building the docker
file
and our docker image
and
uh
that'll be like the preparation stage
along with retrieving application
artifacts or perhaps building it in in
this example we're actually going to
build our own application artifacts
and then you you build the image
and then
and that's done with the docker file
which
again you can learn a ton about
in docker and action and then
you can verify that functionality
um either by
you can verify that the image was built
correctly uh so you can you can do some
things to make sure that the right files
are in there they have right permissions
etc you also do things like
vulnerability scanning once we're pretty
sure that it's a good image
we can tag it and then publish that
image to
a registry for that image to be deployed
somewhere and the goal here is
to build confidence that the right
application
is going to run
like once you actually deploy it into
production which seems like sort of like
obvious
and like oh that should be easy but it's
actually full of
like little gremlins all over the place
in practice
uh
and and docker is here to help us with
that there's a few ways to build docker
images and we're gonna talk about uh
like three patterns and we're really
gonna show
on
this middle one the build and runtime
one so
you know each of these patterns are
useful and appropriate
for
uh different situations
um so let's just name them real quick
there's the all-in-one there's a there's
where you separate the image
that you build your application with
uh from the image that actually contains
the application then there's
uh build plus multiple runtimes so you
might you might create other
specializations so let's look at those
real quick in the all-in-one pattern the
image
what you do is is you actually put the
source code inside the doctor image that
you're going to create and
it has all the dependencies to build
your application you build the
application uh say you're building a job
application you build like you can
actually compile it
uh the application inside the
target image
and
like you write the jar out
or like you in a go line program you
compile
that binary inside the image and like it
just lives on on the image file system
um and it's easy to start with
uh it's good for proof of concepts
but because you have both build tools
and your ultimate application in there
it's
it's got extra stuff
so i'll show you what this all-in-one
means
so
uh we have
or actually let me let me back up and
say like we have
right here
a
super simple
let me see i need to switch this a
little around a little bit
i have a super simple
web application
built in spring boot
the application here is totally
immaterial really
but
you know it's a little web service and
if you hit the home page it responds
with hello docker world
um that's that's not
terribly important we can build this in
like three different ways we're going to
show the different patterns so in the
all-in-one
image so
and i put the links
to each of these docker files
at the bottom of the slide these are all
on github so if you want to check them
out you can
so what this is going to do is it's
going to start with the maven 3 6
and java 11 base image it's going to do
a few things
first it's going to like kind of set up
this project directory
uh and then it's going to expect
that
what it's going to do is going to copy
all the source code inside
the
the image that it's building that's what
this copy command does copies into the
work directory
uh and then it changes the process that
is running the docker build changes into
the work directory
uh it runs a maven build
clean verify
and then it puts
it takes the the jar that's built
um
from
the work
directory and it copies it to slash app
jar
and then finally the entry point
uh this the entry point is a command
that is run
by docker when
the application starts up it's the first
thing that gets run and it's gonna run
java jar which which is gonna run it so
why don't we actually take a look at
that now
pulling up this is the live book
for
docker action
uh let me just we're gonna run these
commands by hand so let me
explain what's going on here first we
have the docker command and it's gonna
invoke the image sub command
and the build sub command off of that
and what this is going to do it says
let's kind of skip to the end here we're
going to it's i'm specifying that we're
going to run the all-in-one
docker file
and this dot means
send the files from this directory into
the build context
uh and then
when that image
builds successfully go ahead and tag it
with this all-in-one
docker in action chapter 10 all in one
tag so let's go ahead and run that let's
see it's going to compile
hopefully this doesn't take too long
let's see
can only take a few seconds
uh previously
dude to do
it's not it's not great to not a whole
lot of fun to look at um
let me let me go back to what's going on
here so because the docker file the from
image the image that we're building from
is the maven jdk
11 image
and we're building our application
inside here and then we just run it
directly from
from within this image and so we're
pulling in maven 36
like the full jdk etc
so
uh this is this is what i call an
all-in-one image or a kitchen sink image
and like it's great you know the our you
can see here that
uh
we built the image and tabix tagged it
tagged it successfully
it's like you know we can do all kinds
of things here we can we can run that
let's just do that now
run
rm
okay
let's see so we see spring starting up
that's nice
um
oh you know what i didn't run it with
any ports exposed let's go back and add
that
let's see 8080
8080
okay so let's see
great so it worked
um
awesome
uh some things that
maybe
we don't like about that
are if we list
the
image repository if we like show the
information about it
like show it show what images are in our
docker action
chapter 10 repository
we'll see
that okay here it is we this is the
thing that we just created a couple
minutes ago and a 709 megabytes like
okay great proof of concept awesome
um but you know there's probably extra
tools in there like we have this like
super duper simple application
so maybe we can do better
alright so the next thing we can do
is we can use what we call
the
build and build plus runtime pattern
where you build and run
your application with separate images
and this is nice because we like
having a all of our our build tools
inside a build image that's that's
that's great i mean like i don't want to
have
um like i don't have jdk 11 or maven 36
installed locally on my machine
and if
i did uh
i don't know what oracle like
come yell at me i don't know building
and running your application are
separate concerns
um and and like there's a while our
build well that while the build of this
application is relatively simple i've
worked in plenty of places where the
build environment required like a
12-page wiki
at least until we automated it with
docker let's try this pattern where we
separate out our build image
or the image that we're building with um
and like that's a distinct thing from
the image that we run with like there's
no inheritance going on there
so we're gonna build application with
one image and then we'll package the
application
artifact into a runtime image
and we and this makes it so that we can
deploy only the runtime which is going
to be
a little similar slimmer and more secure
so first off let's take a look at
the
runtime image okay so now this docker
file is super simple and maybe
it might be better for me to go ahead
and pull this up
over here
my ide side by side
it's right here
okay
vertically
okay
so
here's what we had
uh here's what we have now so you know
these are these are like literally the
same lines at the end
um or very much so except now there's
kind of this assumption that we're
getting
you know our preparation step is is
getting and retrieving the artifacts
from somewhere else
so
how did that happen
or how do we do that
so
again let's see
so i'm going to copy this and the reason
i'm copying this like right out of the
manning live book is just try to kind of
show you that like you can reproduce
this whole thing yourself there's
there's not really much magic
going on here
oh okay
all right so let's explain this command
before i run it
um
so
what i'm gonna do
is i'm going
to
use
that maven 36 jdk 11
image
and i'm just i'm only going to run the
command that i needed to run i i needed
to run maven clean verify
if you see in the original
all-in-one image that's that's all i was
running in here
so actually
move this around so we can see both at
the same time in my original all-in-one
docker file i had maven clean verify and
that was the only thing was going on
so i can go ahead and just i can run
that directly as a container
and then there's some other things going
on here where i have
uh mapped
my local my current directory
i bind i've used what's called a bind
mount and i've
taken a directory on the host the
present working directory which is
interpolated by this shell so let me hit
control c
echo
[Music]
pwd
okay
so on my this is this is the actual
directory
on my mac that i'm working within i just
have
insensitive or non-sensitive directory
names
um
but
uh what's it what it's going to do is is
that's going to be expanded and it's
going to mount docker for mac
it's going to mount that directory
into
this container when it runs it in slash
project
so you can kind of think of
this command that i'm about to run
[Music]
let's go back over here
you can kind of think of this command
that i'm about to run
has like just a transformation of that
uh docker file like back into
um you know i'm gonna give access to the
container
get give give the host directory
uh put that inside the container at
slash project
uh run commands from slash project
that's what this w means this is the
working directory
uh we're gonna use the maven 36 image
that's equivalent to the from
and then we're going to run maven clean
verify
which
are command arguments
so all right let's do that no talking
uh this might also take a minute
let's move back here
which is scrolling and so what we're
going to do is okay so
we're kind of using that build image
that maven
image as the build image and we're
running it as a container
and
it's going to produce an artifact so now
there's a file here in my target my
in the target directory on my local
machine
called chapter
10
0.1.0 jar
and
let's see
target
all right
so that was built just moments ago now
we have an artifact
so this is the equivalent we we've
essentially prepared
uh to build our image we've
retrieved or created the application
artifacts that need to go into our image
and now
we can do
the simple thing
uh we're going to
build our image our the simple runtime
image
okay
so now
we can again
run rm
okay
let's do 81 so you know i'm not
so now that it's a different server
uh let's see
it should work
okay see it's starting up again
change this to be 8081
hooray
okay
all right
so now
image ls let's see what's going on here
okay so this simple runtime image
which
is only 417 megabytes which i know some
of you may laugh
but um
go ahead i guess
it's
it's uh you know about 300 megabytes
smaller and and why is that well
it's because
uh
two two reasons one it doesn't have
maven inside um which has a bunch of
stuff it doesn't have the
uh portions of the internet that were
downloaded during the build process
and it's also using the slim jdk instead
of the full jdk
because the application only needs uh
the sling stuff so it doesn't need like
java effects or like whatever
uh else is in the full jdk now the
application still works the same
so that's cool
now
the last pattern
is that you can
once you've got your image separated out
your application runtime image separate
out you might say like well there are
some extra tools i need from time to
time
like maybe a profiling
tool or
something that performs administrative
jobs that needs all the same application
libraries so
think of like a database migration
or a data
analysis or fix up job where you know
you want to use let's say all the same
code that reads and writes data from the
database
but you don't want to
you want to bake all those tools inside
the regular application image so
what you can do is
separate
out those images
the building of those images
into kind of separate targets and we're
going to show that in
let's show that now actually so i'm
going to close
that work
opposite groups
okay so this is a this is a bit more
sophisticated
um
and this uses
uh
build targets
and you can so in a within a docker file
you can name
every time you say from you create a
build stage
and you can have multiple stages
of builds and produce multiple images
from a single doctor file what this is
doing is this is saying like look let's
start this build stage and we're gonna
name this app image
um
and
then
here's another from so this this starts
a new stage
so this is this is like extending
you can think about it as extending
uh the app image
build stage or and we're going to add
some other tools so like we could uh
copy something else in here this last
statement
is here
to ensure that like it creates another
stage called default and it just like
kind of it's just kind of like an alias
here like default isn't a special term
that like docker knows about
um
but what it's doing is is the last
stilled stage that's defined in your
docker file is the one that is run by
default but let's go let's go look and
see
okay this is this is the hierarchy this
is like what the image hierarchy will
actually look like
so
if you noticed okay we started again
from the jdk 11 slim
uh
and we're gonna build app image
and then
you know when we can go ahead and tag as
we want like it's going to tag that app
image
and then
the app image debug is actually built
from that original app image so this is
just from a visualization of the
different images and layers and so forth
let's build that now
we won't spend too much more time on
this
all right you know what i want to do is
i want to build
let's
i just want to build the
multi-stage runtime to show you what
happens
if you don't
name it specify a stage
okay so see the the key here is that
like i didn't specify
a stage uh to build explicitly and so
because that from app image as default
is the last stage defined in the
docker file that's the one in built
so
there's also
[Music]
a target
see that's why i was messing up
a little bit beginning i called it a
target
instead of the stage names matter i
guess so
we can define
the
stage that we want to build directly
let's do that now stage app image
oops i did it again
all right cool so because we'd already
you know we just basically built all
that um
it was
already it was able to actually build
entirely from cache
but we can build
the debug version
quite easily by specifying that one
and
um turns out
let's see let's go ahead and add a
command just to make it
do something run
yes
[Music]
let's do
just copy a file
okay so
you know
starting from here it said okay
uh everything
everything
[Music]
i'm kind of surprised it wasn't
it's not showing as cached
but that's fine
um the key here is that yeah it's going
to build it's starting from the app
image
uh it runs our copy
and sets the entry point and creates
this other thing
and if we say docker image ls
then oh
let's see i didn't tag it today
this command is getting kind of long
it's feeling like i should be automating
this
let's see
let's just call it out
image debug
all right so that was all cached
all right so now it's here
you